hey guys it is the first of September
and with the start of spring or fall
depending on your hemisphere comes
gaming news as it does basically every
other day let's get going
it's a good day to be a fan of awesome
Japanese games since during the Sony
press conference not one but four hotly
anticipated titles grabbed themselves to
release Windows
we got the teaser trailer a while back
now but atlas has confirmed that persona
5 will be coming to ps4 and ps3 next
year and your trailer for our eyeballs
was shown revealing the protagonist and
is the game setting which will be Tokyo
if turning off u G's into hack and slash
games is more your thing then you may
want to know about Dragon Quest heroes
the newest game in the saga will be
dynasty warriors esque in the same vein
as Nintendo's Hyrule warriors where a
group of Heroes takes on hordes of
classic Dragon Quest enemies such as
slimes skeletons and Dragons obviously
alongside its 2015 release date Sony are
bringing out a seriously awesome looking
silver console complete with a metal
slime dude USB cover over on the horror
front Resident Evil Revelations 2 was
announced officially it's coming next
year and there's a glorious live-action
trailer with live action zombies wearing
brave bracelets to tide you over the
game is coming to ps4 ps3 Xbox one Xbox
360 and PC but is skipping Nintendo
consoles the same core team from
revelations 1 will be developing the
sequel but it won't be featuring Jill
Valentine and Chris Redfield as
protagonists and will instead use a new
setting last but seriously not least is
that blood-borne has been announced to
land in Japan on February 5 well we
don't have release dates for anywhere
else as yet the action RPG developed by
from software will likely land at a
similar time in the US Europe and here
in Australia also the tagging guard
revealed a creepy PR schoolgirl thing if
you count down the hours until Sony
announced yet another ps4 update you'll
be happy to hear that customisation is
on its way the ps4 is 2.0 update and the
Vita's 3.30 update us
set to bring in famed support a pretty
widely requested inclusion the themes
are set to be distributed via the
PlayStation Store and Sony demonstrated
the adorableness potential of this
feature by screening a video during the
press conference which included torah
the playstation cat getting his game on
and a weird man in a suit Obama walked
out for some reason if you splashed out
on a 3ds within the last year you'll be
happy to hear that Nintendo have
announced new 3ds models seriously this
is bullsh it's pretty big news even
though the consoles weren't make their
way to the US until at least 2015
apparently the year that everything in
gaming is happening ever if you do find
yourself in Japan next month you can get
one on October 11 the updated 3ds
feature a new analog nub and two extra
shoulder buttons as for what's on the
inside which is what counts the new
models also come with a stronger CPU and
better 3d image viewing angles if you're
more of an outside beauty kind of person
you'll be glad to hear that these models
support custom covers so you can tell
everybody what your favorite Nintendo
franchise is at just a glance although I
think my golden Legend of Zelda 3d yes
is probably already doing that for me
that's your question of the day let me
know what character or series would make
it onto the custom cover of your 3ds
where you to get one that's all I have
to tell you about today I'll be back
same time tomorrow and be sure to avoid
gaming news until then since that's
really all I have to offer I'll see you
soon